welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
episode 9 the past year was the worst
year of my life both of my parents
almost died repeatedly first my mom then
my dad you can't make this up it's been
an insane I'm writing about it in more
detail it'll be in my book so Andre my
husband and I have spent every day for
the last six months trying to find my
dad help looking everywhere traveling
around the world if it hadn't been for
Andre we wouldn't have made it through
this year so this is a brief podcast
with my dad about what happened to him
and my family in the last year this was
a very difficult interview it flattened
both of us the evening we recorded it
dad's been in the public eye for years
now and his sudden disappearance was
definitely noticed he disappeared due to
a benzodiazepine dependency we both
thought explaining what's gone on in the
last year could help other people avoid
the same hell that were just hopefully
barely getting out of explaining these
personal struggles is really stressful
so this wasn't an easy conversation and
going through these experiences and then
feeling like you owe an explanation to
the world is tough I assume there will
be plenty of questions after this video
and we'll get to those in time please
check out the links in the description
and in the show notes to learn more
about the topics we're about to cover
[Music]
hi dad hard kiddo
it's really nice to be doing a family
update with you rather than about you
yeah well it's it feels like a good
thing from this end of the universe as
well good when was the last time you
used a mic to record anything for
YouTube mm-hmm
last fall likely early fall maybe
September it was long maybe almost a
year yeah yeah a long time so I felt
like a long time too it felt like a very
very very long very long time yes well
in the most Canadian fashion I can
muster what the hell happened eh right
that's what people were asking online
name right right what happened well you
know an accident is when three or four
or five unlikely things happen at the
same time and I would say
happened to me first of all I spent last
January with you in Zurich yep at a
hospital I wasn't in the hospital but I
was there most of the time you're in the
hospital a lot I was in the hospital a
lot yeah well I had to feed you you know
me or make food for you
yeah sure I was their date through all
of January and you were getting some
pretty invasive surgery done on your
foot and then your mom and I Tammy and I
went to Australia New Zealand for most
of February and that was actually not
too bad a trip I felt all right and she
was feeling all right - but we knew her
surgery for what was hypothetically a
relatively treatable cancer was coming
up in March so that was hanging over our
heads although we weren't overwhelmingly
worried about it and then she went and
had her surgery and
they then we were informed six weeks
after that after she had recovered but
was still suffering some pain that the
easily treatable and non dangerous slow
growing malignancy that we were told she
had was in fact something fast growing
with about with a some something near a
hundred percent fatality rate within a
year regardless of treatment mm-hmm like
treating cancer like yeah so that was
deadly we got all we were told that in
about ten minutes and so when we were
just expecting uh well it's not a clean
bill of health at least a we represent a
ssin of what we'd already been told
then she went in to have more invasive
surgery and hypothetically that work but
it created syrup terrible side effects
and that was the start of a whole other
six months long nightmare of trying to
deal with surgical complications which
we did eventually resolved but not until
mid the middle of August in fact not and
literally not until the day of our 30th
wedding anniversary yeah so that was all
hare-raising and stressful to say the
least
I mean you know I've talked about that
but we seem to have a life-threatening
emergency on Tammy's part for both every
three days for about six months and then
I had my own problem start to develop
really in with any degree of severity in
about April May something like that I
had been taking benzodiazepines since
2016 so why be before we get into their
what why why did you start taking
benzodiazepines well in in over the
Christmas vacation in 2016 you and I and
Julian and my son and cami went out to
Vancouver Island to visit her parents
and siblings and when we were there you
and I and Andre your husband ate
something that
didn't agree with any of us and solve a
very severe reaction to that I'm still
on board it was logical conclusion but I
was
well it the same we have the same
symptoms I don't know if I was any more
seriously affected than you or not but I
was freezing cold for about a month I
couldn't get warm no matter how much I
wore I couldn't stand up without
fainting I couldn't sleep I don't think
I slept at all for for something on the
or on the order of three weeks yeah
people like you went on Joe Rogan and
talked about a sulphite reaction you had
and how you didn't sleep and people
commented that oh it's not possible to
stay awake for that long but if you
actually look into sodium metabisulfite
allergies the symptoms that we
experienced aren't unheard of there are
people it's also impossible to stay
awake voluntarily that long that's not
the same as not being able to sleep
those are very very different things
whatever it's possible that when I was
laying there thinking I wasn't sleeping
that now and then I drifted off and
would wake up and not notice I mean I
can't eliminate that as a possibility
but I can certainly tell you that I
slept little enough so that it was
exceedingly unpleasant it's a very long
time to stay awake and when we went back
to Toronto our family physician
prescribed benzodiazepines which are
often used as a sleeping aid and an
anti-anxiety medication and is something
called zopiclone in moving and I hardly
took the EMA vein at all maybe four or
five times but I took the
benzodiazepine the way that it was
prescribed to twice a day point to five
milligrams and that seemed to bring the
symptoms to a pretty rapid halt which is
also part of the reason I didn't need
the EMA vein and then there are so many
other things going on around me at that
time that I never really thought about
it again you know I thought they were
that it was a relatively harmless drug
and I was taking it in a prescribed
fashion at not too high a dose and
I developed symptoms that I now
recognized were associated with its use
weakness on the my left side and like a
feeling of detachment from people around
me people I loved some decrease in the
ability to experience joy but it wasn't
until much later that I actually
associated with the pins does being use
yeah when well when your mom got so sick
my anxiety levels had been climbing up
again well yeah that was unbearable I
mean the response I had if you're told
your parent or your wife of almost 30
years
has no chance and is going to be dead in
the next ten months that's what we were
told that surgery doesn't help and that
chemo doesn't help and that this is a
fast-growing cancer and you're screwed
no matter what right what we heard in
one day yeah anxiety went all over North
America to New York and to Houston and
to LA looking for different opinions
before we decided to settle on surgery
but and everyone gave us the same
opinion yes which was that nothing is
going to help but surgery was probably
the best mm-hmm the best low probability
bet yeah so so so I asked my doctor to
increase the benzodiazepine dose but
what seemed to happen as a consequence
of that was that I just got more anxious
like so again in retrospect it seems
like I had
rather uncommon but not unheard of
reaction to benzodiazepines where
increased dose makes anxiety worse
instead of better
so then at one point when things weren't
getting better and Tami was still in the
hospital I was trying to take care of
her we had lots of help I stopped taking
them entirely and tried ketamine which
is a treatment for depression well that
neither of those were very good ideas as
it turned out so
I had to stop taking
Josephine's entirely
the ketamine oh yeah yeah then I didn't
go then I stayed off them for something
approximating a week not knowing that
that was a very bad idea and I often
think I should have known these things
because I did a lot of scientific
research when I was a graduate student
on alcoholism and I knew that alcohol
and benzodiazepines and barbiturates
were all the same chemical class at
least in terms of their effect on
neurological effects and but what I knew
about benzodiazepines was that they were
comparatively safe compared to
barbiturates which they basically
replaced but that's much less true than
everybody who's taking them hopes and
they're very widely prescribed and I
don't remember what the probability of
developing a dependency on them is if
you take them for more than two weeks
it's 50% I believe it's something like
50% yeah if you take them for two or
four weeks
yeah and over four weeks it's much much
higher most people prescribed them stay
on them for life and that could have
something to do with the fact that
they're very difficult to get off of
yeah well it was unbelievably unpleasant
I mean it was unbearably unpleasant and
so
I started stopping started tapering off
when Tammy was in the hospital but I
couldn't push that too fast because
wasn't bearable and what what do you
mean it wasn't well my anxiety levels
went higher than I'd ever than anything
I'd ever experienced and I also
developed this condition called
akathisia and the best way I can
describe that is that it was like being
jabbed with something look with a prod
like a cattle prod something electric or
something sharp non-stop for hours for
all the hours I was awake was absolutely
I couldn't sit or lay down or stop
moving and even if I did get up and move
it wasn't like that made it better I
just couldn't stop doing it it was
horrible
akathisia is horrible it's a it's it's
well it's like being whipped that's
another way of thinking about it
although I really think I would have you
know this is sounds melodramatic but I
think if I had to pick whipping or arc
áthisá blows it would depend on how big
a whip but maybe not you know obvious
choice has five pronged whips
yes yeah counter nine tails that might
be worse but it was it was plenty bad
yeah and so and things just fell apart
more and more Tammie recovered rather
miraculously in the middle of August and
but I continued my sort of downhill
spiral and ended up in a clinic in on
the eastern seaboard that claimed they
could do a rapid yeah benzodiazepine
detox which was a complete bloody lie
yeah well what we figured was we didn't
realize that there was this physical
dependency until you stopped to try and
do the ketamine and then we tried
tapering and you couldn't stand it
because of the akathisia and so we
thought well let's go get some
professional help right and well and I
went to the clinic on the understanding
that they could do a multi-day
detoxification and treatment for
withdrawal and when I got there what
they told me instead was that they'd
substitute essentially they'd substitute
one benzodiazepine for another which
wasn't the least bit helpful because
clonazepam was already a long-acting
benzodiazepine and they're easier to
wean off than the shorter acting
benzodiazepines and they had nothing to
offer essentially I came out of that
clinic worse than I when I went in so
like significantly worse yes on to more
sedative like drugs in order to dampen
down the akathisia symptoms right switch
wasn't helping much given the fact that
the benzodiazepines were causing the
akathisia yes yeah so and then I went
back to Toronto that's November Nova
and
things maintain their downhill
trajectory apart from the fact that
Tammy was recovering quite nicely which
of course was great but then I ended up
in the hospital in Toronto and the
hospital I ended up went in was also
worse than useless yes so and I don't
remember this part of the it from
December 15th onward you and Andre your
husband took me out of that hospital and
we went to Russia of all places near
Moscow to try a treatment offered by
clinic there that used they use proper
fall and Dec store right right proper
fall too as a heavy heavy sedating agent
it's basically made me unconscious for
nine days yeah so you were completely
out for nine days well I also had
pneumonia which I developed apparently
in the hospital in Toronto oh yeah it
was quite quite entertaining the whole
the whole string of events we got
questions about you know why why on
earth would you go to Russia when you
could get you know world-class care in
North America and the reason for that
was because we had tried the Ashton
protocol we switching over to valium we
tried the Ashton protocol and lots of
people have success with that although
it sounds horrible
lots of people don't have success with
it yeah I'm put out a the first family
update we did was when you went to the
first rehab center in the States and
after I put that out and said this is
what's going on I had hundreds if not
thousands of people respond telling me
how horrible benzodiazepine withdrawal
could be how they couldn't work how they
were pacing around their back yards for
a year and they basically said just keep
him alive
make sure he's psychiatrists that I
spoke with said you know when I asked
him how long the it's easy it was likely
the last they said well it could be two
years and I thought no one could live
like this for two years it's like you
can't live for two years if you're being
constantly prodded with something
excruciatingly ly painful on a
moment-to-moment basis it's just not and
there's no escape there's no relief
that's just not possible wasn't possible
alright sir I mean the reason I did
survive certainly wasn't because I was
enjoying my life the reason was is that
I had family
that I was very attached to and friends
who went
above and beyond the call of duty
helping to care for me but
the experience was
intolerably dreadful and it's so strange
was we're now in Serbia weirdly enough
in Belgrade of all bloody places and
we've been here about two weeks and went
to yet another specialty clinic run by
an anesthesiologist and they modified
the medication that I was taking in
Florida which is where we were last and
I don't know I can't understand it but
virtually all my symptoms have
disappeared I'm still weak if I get up
and walk around I don't have my stamina
but I can think clearer Leah I feel I'm
back to my regular self such as that is
yeah during the mornings and during the
days I can work you know it's very
surprising to me that this happened so
rapidly but it it has and that's why
we're doing this podcast and yeah or
this this this video but and hopefully
the last but Tami is coming she's been I
haven't been with her
for more than a few days since middle of
December and that was partly because I
was in bad shape and she wasn't in good
enough shape to be patient with me she
almost died like every day for six
months like you said and you were in you
were suffering so much that anyone
around you suffered yes because of how
horrible it was to watch it was horrible
so just to back up a bit you went to a
hospital in Toronto and they were going
to make things worse rapidly they
weren't willing because of your
akathisia which was making you crazy
they weren't willing to slow tapered you
down they just wanted to stabilize you
by keeping the benzodiazepines there so
Andre and I found a clinic in Russia
that would actually put you to sleep
using proper Falls so you wouldn't have
to suffer while they took the
benzodiazepines out and doing a detox or
as much
Halla least you'd be unconscious for
that period time and doing a detox on
benzodiazepines isn't recommended you're
supposed to do a slow taper but you're
akathisia was so bad that even staying
at the same dose was dangerous right so
we needed to get rid of that so we spent
time in Russia managed to get it out and
it was or well you guys took a big risk
taking me out of the hospital in Toronto
which nobody recommended the
psychiatrist certainly weren't in favor
of it and taking me somewhere as foreign
as Moscow and and then attempting this
what generally unadvised treatment was
all surreal yeah what was terrifying and
when I woke up
so as I said - that was complicated by
the fact that I double I had developed
pneumonia in both lungs but when I woke
up I was first catatonic and then
delirious I can remember the delirium
that lasted a whole day consisted of a
sort of dreamlike hallucination that I
had been kidnapped by you were you were
delirious for nine days nine days yeah
nine days you remember the last last day
yeah I remember that I was kidnapped by
people
oddly enough who lived in Florida and
they were like very rural backwoods
people landlord a tree people root
Florida tree people yeah and that they
were gonna keep the leader of this
little gang who kidnapped me we're gonna
kill me because the leader was going to
kill me because he wanted to impress his
girlfriend and it was very very vivid
dream that I had while I was awake I
knew I was in the hospital at the same
time I was just one of them and I also
remember that when I first woke up I was
irate because I had been
hands have been secured to the side of
the bed because apparently I was tearing
out the IV tubes that I was connected to
because I didn't want to be in the
hospital I had no idea why I was in the
hospital or where the hospital was or
where anybody I knew was we had to back
up a bit again we had agreed when you
were in the hospital in Toronto like our
whole family had sat down and agreed
that the best option was this rapid
detox in Moscow and you'd been part of
that discussion but when you woke up
after the detox in Russia you couldn't
remember any of that right I remember
being really angry with you when you
first showed up because they were very
limited
yes in ours but I didn't know that it
was this oh man it was so awful it was
we ended up in like the outskirts of
Moscow in a clinic for severely ill
people yeah
and it was like Soviet ask guard guarded
so the visiting hours were two hours
from driving how far are they to come
and visit I was like two hours each way
right right and in in in Moscow winter
winter in in rough traffic in bad
weather yeah to visit an ICU that was
full of people who were in very rough
shape including me oh yeah you fit right
in when you first got there and at first
it was like how oh my god we brought
dad to Moscow and destroyed him well
that's what the doctor told you wasn't
it the first said that oh yeah
under I couldn't even like there was one
day that was so bad I couldn't go in and
Andre went in and they said you know why
are you here of all places in Russian
and Andre said there was no one to help
him in the West which there wasn't we
looked everywhere right and we tried to
clinics and talked to multiple
psychiatrists and none of them could
help and she said great you've brought
him here to die
so and that was you know the scary thing
about the hospital you were in in
Toronto is you had pneumonia that wasn't
picked up until we got to Moscow so when
you arrived in Moscow you had a fever
and pneumonia in both lungs and so when
they sedated you I am the end -
intubated Muse I had to intubate you
during the sedation because of the
pneumonia so we weren't getting care
anywhere and getting off of
benzodiazepines almost killed you on the
place in Russia mmm managed to stabilize
you what it was yeah to some degree like
I didn't seize you was much reduced yeah
when the benzos were finally so they um
they did some plasmapheresis as well to
get rid of the benzodiazepines in your
blood because the half-life of benzos
are so long that even when you stop
taking little dates of that particular
kind thank you early it takes a really
long time for it to get out of your
blood so one of the things they did when
you were under was plasmapheresis to get
rid of all the benzodiazepines so when
you woke up the only good thing that had
happened was you weren't taking
benzodiazepines and you weren't a
Cathie's 'ok we're totally screwed but
you weren't a Cathie's right yes and
that that was a great relief
and then we went when we went to rehab
center for a while in moscow that was
less medical and more physiotherapy yeah
oriented and for a while I couldn't I
couldn't type because I couldn't
remember how to put my hands on the
keyboard I couldn't walk up and down
stairs cuz I couldn't see the stairs
properly I couldn't do a buttons and one
night I got up to use the washroom and
then came back into the my bedroom and I
couldn't remember how to lay down I
tried for about 40 minutes I couldn't
remember the sequence of actions that
would enable me to lay down so this was
probably 2 or 3 in the morning
I ended up calling for a nurse so that
the nurse who was a very helpful person
could come in and tell me how to lay
down so that was very strange kind of
cortical blindness so I stayed in there
for what 2 weeks and then we went to
Florida where we thought it would be
sunny and
easier to recover which might have been
but when I was in Florida the aunt my
anxiety levels were I wasn't a Cathie's
ik most of the time but my anxiety
levels were
unbearably high and net that finally got
so bad that I had family members there
who were taking care of me
you were there of course and Andre but
also my parents my sister some friends
Tammy came for a while my son came for a
while but it got to the point where it
was obvious that just the care of family
members no matter how well-intentioned a
wouldn't be sufficient and Bea was just
too much to ask of people the
responsibility was too great and so
that's when we you at you and Andre had
been communicating with the Serbian
medical clinic for about six weeks
something like that and they'd been
quite helpful five months okay well this
is partly why we're doing this together
is because I don't know all the facts at
at hand yeah but they were helpful they
were helpful
we Andre managed to get in touch with
this
when it can Belgrade where it's not at
least people who are treating you it's
not run by a psychiatrist it's run by an
anesthesiologist which seems to be how
you need to be treated well it's working
for it seems to be working for me at the
present anyways and that's the best
we've got and it's pretty good because I
felt better probably I felt better see
the things about the benzodiazepines too
that I didn't really understand until I
began to decrease their use I was very I
be had to become quite isolated from my
family members yeah it was not most
noticeable I would say in my
relationship with my son but it was like
there was a barrier up between million
people it was noticeable it was
noticeable I thought I thought
attributed that to strange twists and
turns my life had taken in the previous
two or three years because there was no
shortage of strangeness on that front
but and then also I had two strange
muscle weakness that plagued me and I
now realize in retrospect that that was
all a consequence of benzodiazepine use
so using it well this is part of the
reason we're doing this this podcaster
video as well to let people know these
are very widely prescribed drugs and
they are not safe to take for more than
two weeks or a month at the absolute
maximum and if you take them longer than
that and you end up addicted you're
gonna or dependent which means that
you'll suffer withdrawal symptoms on
their cessation you are gonna be one
sorry person some people you know have a
better time of it when they stop their
use than others but enough people have a
terrible time so that it's an absolute
it's a it's a medically-induced epidemic
it's a complete bloody catastrophe here
it's probably worse than the opiate
epidemic and that's really saying
something so and I don't know if I'm out
of it or not you know I mean I'm I have
a hard time believing how much better I
feel that I did two weeks ago it's it's
it doesn't seem plausible so you know
it's possible all the things will just
deteriorate for me again although
I wouldn't I don't feel like that at the
moment I feel like things are put back
together in an important way
fortunately one thing I've been able to
continue doing through all of this as
I'm writing a new book and it's due in
the middle of July and that's going
quite well and I was able to do that
even when I was in these different
clinics hospitalized in all these
different clinics although I don't think
I did any writing in Russia no not till
the very end yeah yeah at the very end
you did before we went to Florida no you
were editing yeah well I remembered one
other thing we were gonna discuss you
know some people okay first of all I've
had a tremendous amount of support from
family members and friends like really I
mentioned this earlier but it's worth
mentioning again people have gone far
beyond the call of duty to help me and
Tammy and I in the last year and a half
and there's been an unbelievably massive
outpouring of public support which has
really taken me by surprise in some
sense because you know it's one thing to
be to express your condolences if you're
discussing someone who like my wife is
suffering from something clearly of her
know of that's clearly not of her making
cancer for example but a dependence is
more ethically questionable right
because you think well everyone thinks
well you know what did the person the
person obviously made some errors in
choice that contributed to this and
that's a reasonable objection but and
despite the fact that
there are many people who
found that their opinions didn't align
with mine let's say the proportion of
negative comments I got about what I was
going through is very small so that was
really something
but nonetheless
one of the things I wanted to talk to
you about today was the fact that what's
the old saying physician heal thyself
right I wrote a self-help book I'm a
psychologist it's like well why the hell
didn't I see this coming and why wasn't
I more cautious and I think those are
reasonable questions why should people
take it well and then that's the next
question is why should people take
anything I say seriously because of that
and I guess what I would say is if
you're gonna wait to learn from people
who don't mistake don't make mistakes or
don't have tragedy into their life
you're gonna spend a long time waiting
to learn something and the second thing
I would say is in my lectures and my
writings
I've never suggested that I was anything
other than one of the people who also
needed to learn this lesson these
lessons so I included myself in the
population of people who needed some
moral improvement and
and then the last thing would be
you you have to make that the decision
about whether or not to attend to
anything that I'm doing based on your
own judgement about what I've done and
said and if you find that that's not
convincing then that's your prerogative
than if you find that it's useful then
well I'm delighted by that obviously and
that's that that's as that's as much as
there is to say well I think one of the
points of doing this podcast was to
inform people so that other people don't
have to go through the same thing you
went through because watching it from
the outside
was the worst thing I've ever seen
definitely and
hopefully educating people on the
dangers of this well that's saying
something cuz we're new awake when they
replaced your ankle last year in January
oh yeah but that was like there was
still an element of yes I was awake when
they replaced my ankle because I was
trying to avoid the general anesthesia
because I didn't want the general
anesthesia hangover I should have just
done the general anesthesia which is
something I realized when they were
hammering my ankle but yeah watching you
in how long you've been in pain has been
significantly worse and I did want to
mention too because people are going to
be wondering why didn't you again why
you didn't get more help in North
America and one of the reasons was oh we
went to Russia we successfully got dad
off with benzos which to clinics in
North America hadn't been able to do we
did manage to do that and the damage
that the benzos had caused and the detox
caused was significant but there wasn't
any akathisia so they brought you back
to Florida because we thought there's no
point in leaving you in a center
somewhere right you can come back you
can stay with family and we can just
wait and maybe it's gonna take two two
years it looked like it was gonna take a
really long time if you were ever going
to recover fully we thought we'll just
it'll be more comfortable in somewhere
like Florida and we waited and it
probably was yeah well Moscow winter was
a little anxiety provoking other than
the medical experience you were going
through it was a little anxiety
provoking so there was Florida and then
the pandemic hit so we didn't we weren't
really able to go anywhere and Andre and
I spent months looking for a place that
would take you and actually treat the
neurological damage done by the
benzodiazepines because this wasn't like
I was when I was 17 and had my ankle and
hip done
I took oxycontin a high level high dose
of oxycontin for a year and getting off
of that I experienced physical
withdrawal no psychological withdrawal
so I'm a like lots of people aren't
aware of the difference between
psychological and physical the abuse the
difference between abuse and dependence
yeah and physical withdrawals means your
body gets used to the drug that you're
on and when you take it away it's as if
your body's missing something yeah so
with yeah so it's actually difficult to
find it's nearly impossible to find
physicians that know how to treat
neurological damage done by
benzodiazepines it turns out we couldn't
find anyone in North America and we
contacted places because being treated
in North America is would be easier than
being treated in somewhere that the main
language isn't English right and so it
took us five months of negotiations to
find the clinic in Belgrade where there
was an anesthesiologist who could treat
you and thank God that he apparently
knows what he's doing
and then we got here two days after we
were Serbia opened so we weren't waiting
around like twiddling our thumbs trying
to figure out what to do with you we
were actively looking for physicians
that could help you but there weren't
any and we were absolutely terrified
that we'd bring you to a psychiatrist in
North America or a center there and
they'd say his anxiety is through the
roof put him on benzos right and then
that would have been terrible so
we did look everywhere and it's been
very complicated yes that's for sure and
it's been very complicated and so you
know maybe we've well we're confident
enough that we've come out the other
side of it at least to some degree that
we were willing to risk making this
interview this video so yeah you know
the reason we're doing it apart from
telling people that they should be
exceptionally careful with
benzodiazepine prescriptions and like a
very large number of elderly people are
prescribed benzodiazepines most of them
women are plenty of men - and that's you
do that at your peril it also increases
the risk of dementia quite substantially
so that's a lovely additional benefit so
watch it it's it's
how strophe that benzodiazepines are
being prescribed the way they are so
broadly and so there's that but then
also we felt that because I don't know
how he'd say it because people have been
party to my certain elements of my
private life and me too there's perhaps
that it was morally obligatory to bring
people who were interested up to date on
what's occurred so so far so good you
know it's been nice to see you and Andre
get a break for at least a couple of
weeks and it's been really nice not to
be terrified out of my mind for
I mean in Florida the best I ever got
was not petrified with anxiety but close
to it
yeah I had that for a few days in a row
a couple of times but here
has a tremor my left hand yeah one of
the things with benzodiazepine
dependence is it increases your seizure
right after you stop taking them
so this is how serious to give an
example about how serious this physical
dependency can be is for some people
even on a low dose of benzodiazepines if
they become dependent on it and stop
they can have seizures that's how that's
how intense the brain changes can be so
you on each Caesar increases the risk of
the next one you've been at a seizure
risk for six months
you're still if you're not on
anticonvulsants so then you have tremors
everywhere and you're a seizure risk
that's ridiculous for six months after
taking after stopping well that's right
completely well it was interesting too
because I was so appalled by what the
benzodiazepines had done that well I I
went from four milligrams a day to zero
last May and that wasn't tolerable so I
went back up but not part of the reason
you did that people would be like why
would you do that you're supposed to
taper first of all if you don't know
about benzodiazepines it's not obvious
that you have to taper but we you have
also went to a psychiatrist to deal with
your worsening anxiety that you thought
was mainly attributed to mom's cancer
and his suggestion was triquet Amin and
stopped the benzodiazepine right so that
was the first psychiatrist we tried yes
right and we went to we saw at least
five of them in different areas before
we got to Russia so it's not like we
didn't give North America a good try
it's just you I mean you ended up you
got worse and worse more what the
psychiatrists they're generally insisted
on doing was quote treating the
underlying problem unquote when you when
the underlying problem was
benzodiazepine withdrawal not some other
issue yeah they didn't know what to do
with benzodiazepine withdrawal so they
tried to treat something they didn't
know what to do with that didn't exist
yeah at least in all probability didn't
exist
yes you got treated by you what you went
to two different clinics and then
multiple other psychiatrists and they
tried to treat your underlying problem
yes which we had to have huge arguments
about no this isn't an underlying
there's no underlying problem this is a
benzodiazepine dependency and we need to
get him off of it but he can't tolerate
it because the akathisia so how do you
make him more comfortable while he's
waiting down and there was they had no
idea what to you know that's right
that's was something they've been very
good at this clinic
yeah and advising you and me for that
matter for the last few months while
I've been trying to yeah my head screwed
on straight again yeah they tried
helping us from afar but we needed more
help than that um so I guess one of the
things we've learned from this is there
may be ways to treat benzodiazepine
withdrawal right that we're not aware of
in North America that I'm aware of
yes there may be ways we'll talk about
this again at some point in the
relatively near future aspect when we're
more certain that what is happening to
me now is working yeah it's only been
two weeks and like it looks great I'm in
way better shape sense of humors wrong
you can listen to music when you're
writing everyday yeah and I can I can
write I can create not just edit yeah
yeah yeah it's a real relief to get my
my love for music back and that's like a
switch being turned on because it was
gone completely and now it's back
completely very very strange so yeah so
well we will talk more about what's
helped if we know that it's helped yes
um then we could suggest to people what
might be tried in the absence of any
other options what they can talk to
their doctor but I'd like to reiterate
you know
I don't remember what I think it's one
prescription either in seven or one
prescription in nine in the United
States is either for opiates or
benzodiazepines so that's a huge
obviously a huge proportion of the
prescriptions and there's it's very
probable that someone in your family is
currently taking benzodiazepine or or
will be prescribed them in the future
for long enough to develop a dependence
it's like people need to know this it's
not good those drugs are for short-term
treatment of stress induced anxiety or
for surgery they are used in surgery and
things that yeah but as a long-term
treatment there are complete catastrophe
yeah and not everybody like you know
they'll be the person or two that'll say
well I took them and I got off of you
know and that's true but if you it seems
if you look at the statistics if you're
older then it's harder you're more
likely to form a dependency right and
maybe that's because your brain isn't as
plastic maybe it takes just longer to
heal from them what's also true of
opiates like not everybody who takes
opiates for a long period of time
develops a pronounced
dependence there's lots of individual
variability but the risk is still
extremely high mm-hmm I had people
messaged me after the video and
September is saying they'd gotten off of
multiple drugs and that benzodiazepines
had been the most difficult by far
mm-hmm on people with experience with
opiates as well or heroin or something
said benzodiazepines wasn't completely
doable
I'd had bouts of depression before
before last fall let's say in my life
and I would have to say those were among
the most among the worst experiences of
my life but I'd have to say that after
searching long and hard for something
that was worse than depression I finally
discovered it in our Cathie's iya
his Depression was remember we talked
about that right and because you had
suffered boats of depression as well as
the arthritis and one
definition we'd agreed on was that being
depressed was like hearing that your dog
had just died yeah remembering that
continually and that's way yeah you
thought that and there was a dog you
actually like a lot you thought well
that's bad but it's not nearly as bad as
depression not even close right not even
close I thought it was going to be as
bad but then my dog died and I was like
nah depression is way worse sucks the
joy out of absolutely everything
can't even see colors vividly like the
joy out of seeing colors which you don't
even think there's joyous as I did with
that but right cuz well with severe
depression you lose positive emotion and
gain a lot of negative emotion but with
this akathisia it was like all of the
negative emotion associated with
depression plus a very high level of
anxiety plus no positive emotion at all
plus the inability to ever relax even
for a moment and so it was
yeah I wouldn't recommend it yes
watch the hell out for
beans they're probably not your friend
or if they are they're not your friend
for very long yeah and one of the weird
things I was prescribed lorazepam for
sleep I didn't take it very often
because I found it didn't work very well
thank goodness but the funny thing about
them especially at a low dose is they
don't or they didn't for me anyway
induce any type of euphoria so when you
take an opiate when I took the oxycontin
I didn't like it but there was some sort
of high that had to do with the pain
medication but with the lore as a man
there was just an absence of something
so I think it's probably a sneakier drug
to be on right because I think that's
partly why I didn't notice what it was
doing to me too is that there was no
immediate effect in the day of taking it
I mean I stopped having that terrible
reaction that we attributed to food and
so that eliminated the insomnia and the
anxiety but there was no noticeable
effect from the benzodiazepines and so I
know just never paid any attention to
them and never occurred to me that they
could be causing me serious long-term
damage you'd also take and SSRIs for
over a decade
yes depressant anti-anxiety medication
it turns out turns out those are not the
same medications I even knew that to
some degree because I knew that
SSRIs the antidepressants were much more
effective long-term treatments for panic
disorder than benzodiazepines you know
but
well it's quite shocking to me actually
that I didn't know despite my
professional specialty that I had no
idea how
catastrophic benzodiazepine use could be
yeah well psychologists don't aren't
psychiatrist psychiatrist prescribed
medication psychologist counsel right
but it's still useful to keep up on the
relevant literature now you know yes
well no I definitely I don't think I'll
forget that yes so you know it's funny
maybe we'll stop with this once I
started to decrease my use of
benzodiazepines I was never tempted to
go back up except right at the beginning
when I went to zero and I had to well
you were gonna have a seizure yeah it
wasn't good you I couldn't even
communicate with you but I thought after
I got out of the Russian hospital that
someone even if someone put a gun to my
head and said
take this yeah I wouldn't well in the
like I think I really think that for me
that it's no overstatement that to say
that for me the consequence of
benzodiazepine withdrawal were worse
than death
so yes that's what it looked like from
the yes well it it you know you don't
want to say something like that lightly
you know but there were lots of times
plenty of times when
it would have been preferable as far as
I could tell just not to be there than
to experience what I was experiencing
when you when you're in pain people who
are in I mean being at a certain level
of pain is like that right if you're
walking around you know anything over
really like a seven or an eight you
can't stand it yeah so that's what it
looked like from the outside um well the
other thing that that the benzodiazepine
withdrawal did that was absolutely
dreadful bus produce a sense of timing
distortion so this was really obvious
when I first woke up in Russia like the
first day that you and I could speak
again you were wheeling me around in the
aisle of the corridor of the intensive
care unit
we were gonna wheel I was gonna be
wheeled around until it was time for
time to eat and I must have asked you
how many times in ten minutes what time
it was probably every 45 seconds yeah
probably something like that
yeah and that's because for me it felt
like you know a substantial amount of
time had passed an hour or two hours
something like that some terrible amount
of time and so not only was I in pain
and experiencing extremely high levels
of anxiety the duration of time had
extended so that it was really
unbearable it was like the days were
just lasting forever and that's thing
that actually disappeared quite a bit
as the akathisia disappeared and it
isn't the case now thank God but it was
it was brutal
it's funny even now you know because
it's somewhat stressful to have this
conversation
I can feel if I lift up my eyes my
eyebrows a bit like you might when
you're interested in something I can
feel that tremors and tremors in my
forehead and that's partly
stress-induced so we should probably
stop talking yeah okay we can call it
today yes
well was good to be able to sit here and
have this conversation we're gonna go
eat a steak that's the theory okay all
right
well thank you for talking with me wow
thanks for
thanks for being here it's been a
healthier
thanks for your help do
yeah well I was
gonna give up and now we're in Belgrade
and seem to have found an answer thank
God
thanks for listening I've linked
everything we talked about in the
description the rare type of cancer my
mom had sodium metabisulfite allergy
symptoms that caused the original
prescription for benzos papers on
paradoxical reactions to benzos benzo
statistics on dependency information on
akathisia something everyone to be aware
of and other people's experiences with
benzodiazepines what my dad went and is
going through isn't as uncommon as we're
told
benzodiazepine withdrawal can be a life
or death situation if it doesn't make
the people who suffer through it so
miserable they're suicidal they could be
at risk for seizures many people do not
make it my dad was forced to detox
because the akathisia caused by the
benzos was intolerable and we had to
abandon the prescribed tapering approach
after many excruciating months detoxing
from benzos is dangerous it nearly
killed him but the state the
benzodiazepines had put him in was more
dangerous and this isn't too uncommon
most of the celebrity deaths we hear
about are benzo related we're told about
the opiates involved in these cases but
benzos aren't as commonly mentioned
Heath Ledger Amy Winehouse Michael
Jackson Philip Seymour Hoffman Whitney
Houston Tom Petty Anna Nicole Smith all
had benzos related to their deaths when
you look at what happened to these
individuals you might think well that
couldn't happen to me but don't be so
sure we had all the resources we could
have and it took us over a year to
remove the drug and stabilize my dad so
that he could function again and not
feel like he was in hell he still has
neurological damage from the benzos and
it's been six months since he stopped
taking them he's still at a risk for
seizures fortunately we found
world-class physicians who are treating
him properly now it was not easy to
locate these people who would have
guessed they'd be in Serbia we are going
to disclose what's helping my dad once
we're more sure that the treatment is
really working
hopefully this podcast will help other
people avoid the horror my family has
had to experience and is still
experiencing because of benzodiazepines
there are hidden dragons everywhere I'm
just thankful my dad is back
talk to you next week